all right one more and I promise you I'm
not going down then we should have
bought that revived feels for the 1500
points provide it I barely had 50 doctor
yeah I'm belia that as well but still
not about investment since this sucks so
much Wow well you keep going down a lot
harder what's up dude but like within
ten seconds of me going down you're down
it because I had to go provide you could
you are on orange but you said there's
no way I'm going near you and you had a
big fire thing behind you and you so
died but at you I put yellow to orange
all bike pump oh wait come on they say
it life to live at the time yeah that's
kind of [ __ ] oh now I know you're really
pretty you yeah I'm play zombies on my
shirt you can't yeah like one of the
things ago right hate won't be be wid da
his jaw open and you come yeah ray bill
huh oh no are you can't close you show
everyone the mystery boxes look I'll
shoot it for you up a long time I get
out I want to save the ammo but I'm
pointing it okay come on I'm jumping
after all this I'm not right now i can
see i can't find out [ __ ] for me right
now Elvis literally right now man I
talked to my parents
Oh
let's just laugh Lumbee you know right
it beat this one you can't close it yeah
I know they're holed up here you I'm how
do you owe this tons can see the door
you cannot bottle yeah yeah that's what
I told it was ok show me the mystery box
right now but here I'm jumping to water
oh so once we've got once we open the
door we can get to it yeah yeah cool
I remember the ipad app for the scam
like ipad zombies feeling good okay what
there's an iPad an iPhone are people
like the zombies and it's legitimately
zombies like that it yes it's very good
I said that there's an awesome app so
yeah it's good it's fought in the second
round it's five shots to the chest
that's as high we've got those points
but Bobby to kill yes there is sweat I'm
out of ammo have arisen uncle oh i got
ya okay i might um look can you did you
have more points did you open that door
here yeah okay well which one pick one
here okay there's this big toe beep all
that fat for a spin loading okay
Juggernog does Joanna
where's the mystery of us are you Gary I
got ballistic knife yes so hard right I
will watch this game finishes it won't
be long cuz we thought I got the friggin
Python oh my god I can't believe I've
got ballistic knife I only got a five
month without a spin oh no no no I'm
dead haha alright man I got dude is cuz
I to our than what happens good thing
one more time could be yeah 115 it
around with doing it out I'm one more
time I love how it takes like 10 minutes
to show us the school screen like remind
us how sheer wheel it's like the longer
to show I can watch me yeah
you